Donald Trump has business dealings all
over the world with Trump in his
president
leaders in at least 18 countries have
more than political interests in the
United States they will also have
potential business leverage to curry
favor with President Trump take China
China is home to the country's largest
state-owned commercial bank the
Industrial and Commercial Bank of China
but it has an office in Trump Tower in
New York City which means that a foreign
government China will be paying its
landlord who also happens to be the
president of the United States nearly
two million dollars a year in rent
Trump has expressed pride in this
arrangement people think I don't like
John I looked at the largest bank in the
world is a tenet of mine in Trump Tower
but it could get him in trouble a
section of the Constitution called the
emoluments Clause so as presidents can't
accept payments or gifts from foreign
governments the founders added it during
the Constitutional Convention of 1787
because they were worried about foreign
governments using money to influence
American politicians but it's never
really been tested by a president Ronald
Reagan George HW Bush Bill Clinton and
George W Bush all has business ventures
before entering the Oval Office but they
entrusted their businesses and
investments to outsiders who they didn't
communicate with while in office this
arrangement is called a blind trust
which is also what Donald Trump calls
his plan to put his children in charge
of his business but as long as his
children can talk to him about the
business this won't exempt him from
conflicts of interest you can see by if
you look at Japan when Trump met the
country's Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a a
few days after the election Ivanka Trump
was also there at the time Ivanka was
working to close a business deal between
her clothing line and a Japanese company
called Sunday International a company
whose largest shareholder happens to be
a state-owned Bank controlled by the
Japanese government Ivanka's old company
is still part of her father's company so
if they were to put pressure on debate
to finalize the deal Trump would benefit
financially and even if count keeps
Ivanka out of future meetings with heads
of state they'll still have our husband
Jared Kushner ear trump son-in-law will
serve as a senior advisor vice president
Mike Pence has tried to downplay Trump's
conflict
of interest if his kids are running the
business he's and if we're talking about
buildings here if he doesn't divest
himself of the business a lot of people
are saying turn it into cash he's going
to know who what the kids are doing
business with in fact there was just a
meeting in the last few days with some
of his business partners from India
doesn't that create a tremendous danger
of a conflict of interest well I can
tell you in a recent interview after the
election the president-elect summed up
his view of his interest in his business
life with two words he said who cares
but his actions indicate that he does
care after the election Trump met with
British politician Nigel Faraj during
their meeting complained about a
proposed wind farm wrecking the view
from his Golf Course an Aberdeen
Scotland Trump reportedly urged Faraj to
oppose the proposal and though nothing
has happened so far from willingness to
mix private and political matters
creates the impression that he might be
willing to trade political favors for
personal profit in Turkey that seems to
have happened already after Trump called
for an American ban on Muslims Prime
Minister air Dhawan demanded that his
name be removed from the Trump Towers in
Istanbul but when a military coup
threatens air diwan's power Trump
expressed his support that was a quick
coup I was actually surprised to see how
well it was handled earned a1 back down
and Trump's name remains on the towers
since Trump refuses to disclose all of
his business dealings we can't know how
many others might exist but the one that
looms largest is Russia a leaked
intelligence report indicates the Putin
and the Russian government may have
compromising material on Trump but we
don't need that verified report to know
that the relationship between the two
was odd Donald Trump and Vladimir Putin
launching a mutual admiration society of
sorts and want to be complemented by
that former KGB all the while I think
when he calls me brilliant I'll take the
compliment okay because Trump has
refused to release his tax returns we
don't know if he owed money to rational
oil billionaire it's close to Putin the
discussion in the region certainly and
intelligence services that deal with
Russia is that his behavior looks like
someone who may be compromised or maybe
concerned about something and
he knows what that is if it's financial
ties or financial leverage if it's
something more than that I don't know
the only way for Trump to deal with all
these conflicts of interest is to sell
his companies and then put someone
besides his children in charge of the
financial proceeds Senate Democrats have
introduced a bill that would require
Trump to do this if this doesn't happen
we'll never really know whether Trump is
putting the American people first or his
business interest
[Music]